r
compenser. Bref, tout un dossier
compliqué avec Jacaudrey
Charbonneau.
- La justice est sur le bord
du gouffre. Et ça fait l
qu'on a des signaux d'alarme.
- Le constat de la bâtonnière
du Québec est alarmant.nnnnnnnnc
- La principale cause
de la crise  v v v v vient,
c'est le sous-financement
du système de justice au Québec.
- Dans les palais de justice,
de sécurité et de juges.
Encorepupupupupuis la décision
de la juge en chef de la Cour
du Québec de modifier l'horaire
moins de temps en salle de cour,
étant donné la complexité
des causes récentes.
les dernières années, qui pour
la juge en chef justifierait un
ratio de délibéré de 1 pour 1.us
exposer les faits, je ne prends
pas position.
- Le min
Barrette, lui, a choisi
son camp; après avoir dénoncé
cette décision unilatéraleililie
en mode solution.
SIMON JOLIN BARRETTE, ministre
de la Justice du Québecjejejejer
des ressources supplémenta
à donner des juges
supplémentaires, effectivement,
mais il fififififififififififif.
On ne fera pas uniquement
ajssssssssssssssources pour
avoir le même résultat,
c'est pas acceptable.
isisisisisisisisisisisisisisisi.
Me DAPHNÉE CREIGHTON,
avdédédédédédédéfense
- Avec la décision de la Cour
du Québec, ça rend le travail
ctctctctctctctctctctctctctctctc,
jusqu'à Kuujjuaq, où cettedededd
sporadiquement.
- Juste ce matin, j'ai vu untet.
On est en novembre et Monsieure.
- Le ministère de la Justice
du Québec évalue à 50 000
qui sont à risque d'être
abandonnés en raison de délais
déraisonnables.
- Les personnes victimes vont
sentir que leur vécu est moins
important, qu'on invalide
- Le Directeur des poursuites
criminelles et pénales assure
qu'il va prioriser les dossiers
de violence conjugale
si les délais se poursuivent,
car le danger avec l'arrêt
miner la confiance du publicene.
Ici Jacaudrey Charbonneau
Radio-Canada, M